we introduce a new data structure the
bilateral grid which enables real-time
Edgware image processing 2d images are
lifted onto a coarse 3d grid where the
z-component corresponds to intensity as
a result points across a strong edge are
distant in the grid we introduce slicing
an operation that exploits this property
to extract a discontinuous 2d image from
a smooth bilateral grid we demonstrate a
variety of real-time edge aware
algorithms using the bilateral grid we
demonstrate real-time bilateral
filtering on a noisy 12 megapixel input
the user can explore the parameter space
while getting real-time feedback on the
whole image we zoom in to show the full
resolution of the image real-time
feedback makes it easy for the user to
fine-tune filter parameters we further
accelerate the bilateral filter on video
by sampling a random 10% of the input
pixels subsampling causes swimming
artifacts shown on the Left we eliminate
these artifacts by applying a temporal
exponential filter shown on the right we
demonstrate the real time video
abstraction technique by Veen ruler and
colleagues on HD video
we adapt real-time video abstraction to
follow a point of focus here controlled
by the mouse pointer elements that are
farther away from the point of focus are
more abstracted we first compute the
distance to the point of focus and cross
by lateral filter it with the input
image to create an adapted importance
map that respects the edges of the image
we use this map to composite the levels
of a bilateral pyramid the rest of the
abstraction pipeline remains unchanged
note that our method is efficient enough
to compute five bilateral filters per
frame and allow parameter adjustment
while the video plays
transfer the look of a model photograph
to an input video in real time our
result captures the tonal balance and
level of detail of the model in the
spirit of the work Baybayin colleagues
our method enables on-the-fly adjustment
of parameters on live HD video compared
to existing techniques that require
offline processing our approach makes it
easy to modify the level of detail and
adjust the overall tonal balance of this
shot as it plays we demonstrate
bilateral grid painting by locally
modifying the hue while respecting
strong intensity edges the initial
mouse-click locks the brush to an
intensity level the brush is aware of
edges and does not paint across
intensity discontinuities
for instance the brush does not affect
the white wall by the door
our method runs in real-time on the GPU
we update the entire 2 megapixel input
on every frame
we apply the same technique to locally
modify tone mapping parameters we adjust
exposure parameters on this 15 megapixel
HDR panorama
we paint over the gate to correct the
overexposed region notice how the bars
are unaffected
you
similarly the windows are unaffected
while the overexposed dome is corrected
our GPU algorithm updates the entire 15
megapixel image on every frame
we demonstrate scribble and
epilation using the bilateral grid we
scribble on the input image shown on the
left
the extracted influence map is shown on
the right
we use the influence map to drive a
color shift the white scribbles cause
the cloth to change from red to blue
while the black scribbles protect the
candies we zoom in to show the full
image resolution